ich habe die große ehre mich jetzt eine
generationenfrage situation zu wenden 75
jahre nach dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs und der gründung gefeierten
nation erleben wir erneut einen großen
weltweiten kampf wir haben uns gegen den
unsichtbaren kampf eingesetzt gegen das
virus china mit zahllosen toten
empfehlen denn da wir haben den einen
panischen staaten die entschiedenste
mobilisierung seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
eingeleitet wir haben ein rekord
versorgung mit beatmungsgeräten zum
beispiel dargestellt haben die ich auch
mit partnern über laute welt geteilt wir
haben unsere vitalität rate seit april
um 85 prozent gesenkt drei impfstoffe
sind in der letzten klinischen
entwicklungsstufe der stellen an
massenproduktion er planen das schon
damit sofort nach der verfügbarkeit der
mit games werden kann
wir werden das virus besiegen wir werden
der conti ein ende setzen und werden
einsteigen in eine neue ära noch nie da
gewesener prosperität und des friedens
angesichts dieser lichten zukunft hätten
wir die nation ansprechen und
verantwortlich machen die diese klage
auf die menschheit losgelassen hat die
sozial fina hatte zuerst einmal die
reise mein land untersagt ließ aber
flügen ins ausland und in die welt zu
china und viertem einreiseverbot und so
konnte das virus sich verbreiten die
chinesische regierung die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die
praktisch von china kontrolliert wird
haben fälschlicherweise erklärt es gebe
keine hinweise auf eine übertragung von
mensch zu mensch später hieß es
fälschlicherweise im turm freie menschen
würden die krankheit nicht verbreiten
die vereinten nationen müssen china
verantwortlich machen für dieses handeln
china gibt jedes jahr aber millionen
tonnen kunststoffe will mehr zerstört
korallenriffe und entlässt mehr
taktisches quecksilber in die atmosphäre
als jedes andere land der welt mit
kohlenstoff emissionen kinder sind das
kapital für die der vereinigten staaten
und die zahlen steigen schnell weiter
nachdem ich mich aus dem einseitigen
pariser klima war einkommen
zurückgezogen hatte die co2 emission
letztes jahr deutlicher gesenkt als
jedes andere land
wir müssen an diese leistung usa denken
und müssen sehen was jener angerichtet
hat wer die steel americas einfach des
grafen und das kann ich mir nicht bieten
das nicht wenig vereinigten staaten an
der effektiver situation sein sollen und
müssen sie sich auf die wirklichen
probleme der welt konzentrieren
terrorismus unterdrückung der frau
zwangsarbeit drogenhandel menschenhandel
handel mit sexuellen opfern und
ethnische säuberung religiöser
minderheiten amerika wird immer die
menschenrechte verteidigen an der spitze
wir wollen mehr chancen vertrauen wir
wollen die jungs qualität
entkriminalisieren gegen den
menschenhandel vorgehen und ungeborene
kinder schützen
sie wissen auch dass der wohlstand
amerikas die grundlage für frieden und
sicherheit überall auf der welt ist in
drei kurzen jahren haben wir die größte
volkswirtschaft der welt weiter
ausgebaut und nehmen das bald wieder auf
unser militär ist deutlich stärker
geworden
sie haben 25 billionen dollar in den
letzten vier jahren führen sie medizin
aufgewandt wir haben
das stärkt die mediziner weltweit ohne
dass jemanden demnach gerne
wir sind denen jahrzehntelange verstöße
chinas im handel vorgegangen andere
länder zahlen heute einen fairen anteil
zum beispiel im militär binden müssen
wir haben neue abkommen mit gott carla
mexiko und el salvador geschlossen um
den menschenschmuggel zu unterbinden
gestehen auch an der seite der menschen
in kuba nicaragua und wähler bei dem
gerechten kampf dort für freiheit wir
haben uns zurückgezogen aus den
schrecklichen juli abkommen mit ihm
geraden und haben gegen den wichtigsten
weltweiten tourismus förderer
entschieden gehandelt
wir haben auch al bagdadi töten lassen
und den größten terroristen der welt
soll ihn an die töten lassen
wir haben einen frieden zwischen serbien
und dem kosovo in die wege geleitet
haben einen entscheidenden frieden im
nahen osten verbreitet nach
jahrzehntelanger erfolglosigkeit israel
bahrain die vereinigten emirate haben im
verhalten haus ein entscheidendes
abkommen unterzeichnet andere staaten
kommen hinzu das gilt schnell alle
wissen dass das großartig ist für die
welt diese epoche machen den
friedensabkommen sind eine neue phase im
nahen osten wir haben mit einem anderen
weg auch andere ergebnisse erzielt
deutlich bessere ergebnisse
wir haben diesen weg geschrieben und er
hat funktioniert wir werden bald neue
friedensabkommen anbieten können und ich
bin optimistischer für die zukunft der
region
es gibt kein blut im sand diese tage
sind hoffentlich vorbei
die vereinigten staaten arbeiten auch
daran den krieg in afghanistan zu
beenden und wir bringen unsere truppen
nach hause
liga erfüllt sein geschick als
friedensstifter frieden durch stärkere
wir sind heute stärker als je zuvor
unsere waffen sind hoch entwickelt
weiterentwickelt worden
mehr denn je zuvor man konnte sich das
früher gar nicht vorstellen
und ich bete zu gott dass berlin
seit jahrzehnten schlagen die gleichen
läden stimmen die gleichen gescheiterten
lösungen vor
globale lösungen zu lasten der eigenen
bevölkerung aber nur wenn man sich um
die eigenen bürger kümmert kann man eine
wirkliche grundlage für zusammenarbeit
bekommen
als präsident habe ich die geretteten in
modellen vergangenheit inter mir
gelassen
amerika zuerst habe ich gesagt genau wie
wie das mit ihren ländern machen sollten
das geht in ordnung so sollten sie es
machen
ich vertraue darauf dass im nächsten
jahr wenn wir in person ab
zusammentreten werden wir eines der
großartigsten jahre der geschichte
erleben können und hoffentlich auch
überhaupt in der geschichte der welt
vielen dank gott schütze sie alle
schütze amerika und die vereinten
nationen